欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来学习关于优品爆品提升的实战方法
首先我们为什么要提升优品总量
对我们的店铺有什么样的好处呢
我们来看一下提升实力优品跟优品爆品对我们店铺到底有什么样的好处
第一个好处就是我们店铺里面80%以上的流量
都来自于优品
而优品中的80%的流量又都来自于爆品
店铺产品那么多
我们的时间和精力都是有限的
我们只有管理好我们店铺的优品跟爆品
那么我们的店铺的总流量才能更加的稳定
效果才会更加好
第二个就是能够增加更多产品进入一起搜索引擎
可以得到更多的曝光的机会
第三个就是这些产品能够得到更多的报名的机会
和被系统圈进各种场景板块进行展示
获得更多的免费的流量
第三个就是我们有更多优品跟曝品
就能够被系统圈品进行占卖投放
获得更多免费的额外流量
第五个呢
如果我们这些优品跟曝品总量非常多
那么他本身是不是覆盖了非常多的关键词
那么这些关键词就会有更好的排名
而且他的排名越靠前
那么这些产品跟店铺的总流量就会更加的肯定
第六个就是免费的推荐流量
现在是非常大的
所以这些推荐的流量只会推荐那些沉淀效果比较好的产品
所以这些优品跟爆品都有机会获得
更多的免费流量
第七个就是优品跟爆品本身
它数据积累的比较好
那么直通车推广的时候
它的成本会更低
效果会更好
因为我们直通车推广的时候
它的成本会跟你本身的数据的积累
是有一定的相关性的
所以这个板块很多人就忽视了
那么你推广一个数据非常好的产品
和一个没有什么数据的产品
那么他们的成本是截然不同的
接下来我们来看一下它的优品模型
现在已经是升级了
我们去看一下具体升级成为哪些类型的优品
那么现在的升级的话
把原来的这产品成长分替换成为优品运营里面的七大品质
也就是之前你看我们都是按照用分数来衡量
用具体的分数来衡量
现在的话是不通过分数来衡量的
是通过具体的数据来衡量
这七大品质的话
它可能会通过具体的数值来进行衡量
这里面有三大通用品质和四大行业品质
三大通用品质这个平台新品跟报品
是我们之前也有的
原实力优品也就是现在的实力优品的话
它会在11月更新
但是它的更新的话
也跟之前应该差别不大
但是它的方法还是通用的
那么四大行业品质呢
这些的话要求就比较高一点
而且它这种基本都是属于一些精品权益比较多的
一些商家去进行提升的
比如说国家真选品
这些的话一般都是那些行业
国家馆啊还有那些
最近某些国家
南海产品偏好的品类
这些都是根据后台系统
签订的
这个话一般来说
基本都是人为通过数据去判断之后
签选出来给我们这些商家去发产品的
第二个就是行业服务力
这种就是针对某些精品的店铺
他需要认证各种报告等等这些证书越多
那么他的服务就越好嘛
所以说这个的板块的话
也是硬性指标
也就是你有就有,没有就是没有的
第三个呢就是内容竞争利品
也就是我们有视频的
优质的视频, 主图视频
还有我们去发的一些视频在产品上面
那么这种视频讲解的
还有卖点信息的都能成为
内容
竞争利品
第四个就是价格竞争利品
人有我连
高价性价比
这种的话
通常来说
并不是所有的行业都有的
有些行业
基本都是比较高价的
那么这些
低价的
基本都是可能是一些比较落后的国家
比如说
东南亚
非洲
这些国家可能对价格比较敏感的
那么这种
产品
或者是你要做这些市场的
可能这个就非常有优势了
这就是升级后的七大品词
那么升级后他有哪些权益呢
第一个就是
专属广告助力可以获得平台
搜索跟推荐的扶持
更多站内站外的资源曝光这些机会的扶持
第二个就是有更多的透传的渠道
比如说在首页有些板块可以展示
在搜索列表也有一些内容可以展示
在商品词营业也会出现一些信息
买家导购低于场景这些低于买家心智这些去做更多的透传
为了帮助商家获得更多的商机
那么这个就是我们商品成长后的新模型
我们后期的运营以及店铺的各种操作或布局
都是根据这个新的模型去布局的
这样我们才能够更加符合平台的规则
才能够获得更多的流样
那么这个就是新的商品模型
我们一定要重视起来
并且把它理解透彻
然后再去应用
接下来我们就去看一下后台
它具体哪些板块已经升级了
那么我们打开之后
我们看到这个商品运营工作台
以后它就会改名成为优品运营
现在的话板块主要是三个板块
还差四个板块
在这里到时候也会在这里更新
四个板块一共七个品质
现在我们看到的是比如说这个新品
平台新品
新品的话你要知道它的规则
你要点这里就知道规则了
这里就是平台的新品的一些综合数据
也就是你店铺现在这些新品表现数据怎么样
以及下面这些现货还有定制的
就是这些新品的这些数据
这些数据你可以去参考去挖掘
比如说新品有哪些效果比较好的
我是不是可以考虑去推广或者是绑定问顶顶展
去让它的流量更加好
来实现我们的寻盘增长
那么这个平台新品的规则呢
在这里就是这个比较难去衡量
因为这是算法去挖掘的
同时也是我们有些行业有一些定招的
但是有些行业是没有的
并不是所有的行业都有
那么报品我们来看一下
这里也是一样的
平台报品
这里的数据都是你店铺的整体的报品的总数据
那么下面也是分为这些板块
RTS和定制
这是单品的一个数据
那么它的规则是在这里
你要按照这些规则
你只要符合规则就可以了
我们做所有的
运营操作都要基于规则
我们要把规则理解了
然后
再根据这个规则去操作
就能够得到平台更多流量的扶持
所以一定要重视规则
中间的这个是准报品
准报品也就是
它离报品的指标还差一点点
那么我们可以从这里看一下
比如说这里
这个产品是近90天
TM跟询盘的元素要达到
那么20个的时候
它才能成为报品
但是呢
现在它的当前数据是9个
那么9个它就没有成为报品
所以我们在推广的时候
或者是说我们在挖掘哪些产品
更有潜力成为报品的时候
我们就通过在这个准报品里面去看
看哪些是比较接近这个指标的
那么我们就对这些产品
进行重点的流量扶持就可以了
那么这样就更加容易成为我们的报品
语言实例优品的话
它的规则目前还是按照语言来的
但是等它更新了之后
其实不会变化太大的
到时候我们也是根据这个报品规则一样去把
实例优品的规则先理解清楚之后
我们再开始去操作就行了
那么这个实例优品它里面数据
都基本的是比较好的
所以说我们在重点关注和推广的时候
也要重点关注原来这些实例优品里面的一些
极有潜力的产品
那么这个就是优品的后台
到时候我们可以自己详细的了解一下
看看各个指标
看看各个优品的标准规则
这些都要了解清楚
看看能获得的油量的权益都有哪些
你去多了解一下
那么你就知道它的好处和怎么样去操作了
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们来讲解
具体怎么样去提升
爆品和实力优品
以及优品的总量
来提升整个店铺的总流量
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里